so they're getting there but you know as
a movement the black speculative arts
movement and afrofuturism
uh really had to have to speak to black
futures
that just wasn't being done but the
black speculative arts movement
we call it b stamp for short these bcm
festivals that have been going on across
the country
they've been expanding in the us
embraced by canada
in europe and in south africa
the sheer poster art itself visibly done
by stacy robinson and others
is worthy of an exhibition i was lucky
to have the chance to be part of a
futures
computer mixed reality lab called
dynamic lab
and they were opening themselves up to
the community to see
how their mixed reality technology could
help augment
the future visions of their communities
surrounding them
and i got this vision of what if we had
a map of wakanda
and as we went through the different
regions of wakanda
we saw people's alternative visions of
the future
so we actually created a little demo of
that and it was really fun to
to see it come into existence and we
even put bosco conti there
uh singing afrofuturism in this little
blurb
you know ahmed best he played jar jar
binks in star wars
he came to uh the studio uh
with a with an idea of a black uh star
trek comedy and they're like what are
you
what are you saying black people aren't
interested in the future and that really
struck me and him
that wow you know the white patriarchal
structure doesn't get it that
afrofuturism
is something that can feed not only
black souls but
everyone's soul in creating more
varieties
of imagination in talking we kept coming
back to the same point that usually when
we're in the room where the only people
of color talking about
the future and he said
why don't we create a podcast together
so we did and we call it the
afrofuturist podcast where i met for an
hour
with one one-on-one has these um
in-depth conversations
with people that we don't usually see so
the afrofuture's podcast
is in its third year right now and so
we are trying to uncover the stories
of black people and others that are
doing work about the future
so that's part of what we do so at
dynamic land i
met a great white ally of mine and
friend
eli kuzminski and together
we created a game called afro rhythms
from the future
we really realized we needed a game that
spoke to the black experience
and to people of color and indigenous
people we decided to take an existing
forecasting game called the things in
the future
a great game by stuart candy and jeff
watson
we've play tested this game in a number
of venues and with the
help of a research creative research
group called the fathomers
it's a card deck of about 100 cards
people have different roles that they
play
as traveler seer or elder and
they then get dealt a set of cards to
play their role
now this game what we noticed and from
folks like jake dunnigan and dave
mcgonagall who've done work on this
dave mcgonagall was super better in
using games to heal people
we thought about this game as a way to
help rework
our memories rework black memories
by creating new scenes and new futures
that renew positive associative neural
pathways you see the regions of the
brain
that celebrate the past or that form the
past
also form our futures in the same
regions through mri studies
so what if we used gaming to heal trauma
as a call for a futures therapy of the
mind
to jam and heal the epigenetics of black
trauma
what if we create this community futures
literacy program
with a black perspective in mind that
can support healing young and adult
minds
the california blacks bucket of arts
movement is launching in july
and in partnership with the museum of
children's arts mocha
and game heads we're about to launch our
imagining with afrofuturism initiative
the black future school the community
future school that is
where black futures matter we're really
intentionally thinking about the
community future school to increase the
literacy
of futures thinking with everyone
starting with the black perspective in
mind
because what we're noticing with
activists and people right now
that the movement needs an imagination
to think further
and it's provocative too like defunding
the police is great as a provocative
point to talk about the redistribution
of resources or to increase resources
for everything
and how do we use that as a starting
point to recreate and reimagine our
core institutions so having a community
future
school in place with young people young
adults
older people people in general where
black futures matter
will help to enable people to see the
signals around them
of the future and to weave them in
storytelling scenarios that they share
with each other
through our game through other types of
games to really
envision the future of their communities
together what we envision is an
equitable futures network of california
a regional network
where communities from indigenous people
to lgbtq communities
can share and demonstrate and showcase
their visions of the future